hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between adult anderson and paul
charles morphe uh that would took place
in paris uh and things are not great for
adolf andersen as this is already the
10th game of the match and the score is
currently six wins morphe and only one
win anderson and as you know it's first
to seven win so if morphe wins this game
with the black pieces then morphe takes
the match by uh well just by just
crushing anderson here with a score of
seven to one uh two more draws were
played but the draws do not count in
this match so a very very uh tough
position for for anderson but he has the
white pieces and it's very interesting
what he will choose for his basically
last attempt at taking down morphy he
will once again go for the opening he
tried it is of course the grand opening
and it is a three
in theory also known as the anderson
opening but uh some refer to it as the
grand opening so uh what's different in
this game than in the previous two well
we already mentioned that at that
particular point in the game uh anderson
played d4 but this time he's gonna
castle and that's gonna be different uh
if i'm not gonna be explaining um
anything much up up until that point uh
of the game so if you haven't been
following the
match from the beginning do do start and
you know you will
have a better grip on on what's
happening so here we have e5 by morphe
but basically anderson is trying to play
a certain line of the sicilian defense
with the white pieces so here we have c4
knight to f6 knight to c3 and d5 morphe
of course grabs the center we have
cartridge captures and now e3 now we
have bishop to e6 morphe again placing
his bishops on e6 and d6
knight to f3 attacking the pawn and just
bishop to d6 morphe defense with bishop
to e2 and now morphy castles and now in
the previous two games where anderson
employed the grand opening he always
played the d4 but now anderson just
castles here and this is his improvement
for this game and it is now as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
so morphe trades on c3 as he did in the
previous two games we have b captures
and now f5 and now his position is um
uh well just very enjoyable his bishop
pair is very nicely placed here he can
play e4 at any point open up this dark
square bishop he can bring the queen
into the game he can bring the rook into
the game so very very easy to develop
here with black but anderson obviously
has something prepared he plays d4 and
morphe happily advances the pawn to e4
now gaining this diagonal for his dark
square bishop we have knights to d2 and
now rook to f6 uh
you could jump in with the queen right
away but it doesn't really do all that
much simply h3 or f4 uh and uh well
there's just not much uh black can do
here so instead rook to f6 morphe wants
to bring another attacker into the game
and now uh anderson plays f4 uh he says
all right this diagonal is gonna remain
closed and if you capture an f3 alpha
then knight captures and this knight
will be an excellent defender here now
if anyone is is you know better here
it's definitely white i have a
better center and your bishop pair will
not be all that impressive so instead
after f4 morphe says all right i'm not
capturing that i'm just going to play
rook to h6 and now i might consider
bringing my queen to h4 depending on
what you play and here anderson plays g3
he stops it right away
although you could play bishop to c4
it's a very interesting move now you
can't play queen here because just
bishop captures on e6
but it's it's a very interesting line
and how bishop captures an e6 rook
captures queen to b3 and what do you do
you have to defend the rook somehow
either with the king or or with the
queen doesn't really matter we're going
to capture on b7 and win the rook here
uh so uh if anderson played for example
this bishop the c4 move murphy would
have to wait with his plan of bringing
the queen here but okay anderson not
interested in that he wants to play
knight to c4 instead so here g3 taking
away the h4 square from the from
morphy's queen and now knight to d7
morphe now is ready to bring the rook to
the knight to f6 then maybe to g4 uh we
have knight to c4 now we're ready to
bring this knight over to the e5 square
not interested in this bishop because
this bishop isn't really doing anything
and uh morphina says all right that's
not happening we're gonna eliminate this
knight so bishop captures uh we have
bishop captures with check king to h8
and now rook to a2 anderson says all
right now my rook is also guarding the
second rank so uh not uh
and not going to be a problem defending
this position queen to e7 morphe is
ready to bring the other rook into the
game and now a4 anderson grabs more
space on the queen side we have knights
to f6 and now queen to b3 putting
pressure on the b7 pawn so c6 morphe
defends it
and now bishop to e6 uh going after this
f5 pawn but uh morphy just says all
right thank you for uh giving me a free
move uh rook 8 to e8 and now you can't
really capture the pawn because if you
capture upon g6 and the bishop is
trapped so anderson has to bring the
bishop back we have bishop to c4 and now
knight the g4 by morphy
and it's a
tricky position to play uh the knight is
attacking e3 the the h2 pawn is attacked
twice so white really has to thread
carefully here and anderson does he
plays rook to g2 uh it is the by far the
best plan uh you want to play bishop to
e2 and kick away this knight the problem
is if you play bishop to e2
you're gonna lose the h2 pawn so first
rook the g2 so the rook remains uh here
the defending the h2 pawn and now we're
preparing bishop to e2 so rook to b8 now
morphy with the idea of uh
opening up the b file and the bishop to
e2 attacking this knight and now morphy
just brings it back he says all right
for the moment let's bring the knight
back i'm gonna uh
bring it back into the attack
when the opportunity will be right and
now c4 uh anderson says all right we've
um calmed down uh everything on the king
side let's now uh improve our position
in the center and what do you play here
uh morphe starts with b6 and now bishop
to b2 by anderson this is a great square
for the bishop uh and if the position
opens up could be very unpleasant for
morphy's king we have queen to f7 now
okay you can't play a move like c5 maybe
white had some ideas of doing this
because the queen is on b3 so anderson
brings it back and now morphe bishop to
e7
we have bishop the c3 uh and now morphy
says uh all right well we could just
continue re-maneuvering our pieces with
nothing really happening in the position
i'm just gonna play rook to g8 i'm going
to play g5 bust open the position i'm
gonna win the last game of the match and
that's it i win the match and i'm the
greatest player in the world
but anderson says uh all right if if
that's what you want i'm just gonna play
a5 here uh a totally uh you know an
unrelated move on the queen side with a
pawn
we have bishop to d6 by morphy and now a
captures on b6 we have eight captures
and now rook to a1 so by
allowing this um so by playing this
maneuver rook to g8 and with the idea of
playing g5 he allows anderson the a1
square for the rook having an open a
file and now the rook can be lifted over
to a6 and even if for example g5
captures and rook captures then even the
rook to a8 will be possible at some
point and morphe doesn't care here a
modern player would probably play
something calm like a rook to b8 push b5
create a pass pawn and play play on that
uh but morphy says no let's just finish
this uh quickly not that morphy plays g5
uh and understand happily captures with
f captures and g5 rook captures on g5
and now there are a lot of
a lot of interesting options here for
anderson one is particularly nice but
for some reason anderson just doesn't
like this choice
and that's c5 c5 is just a killer move
uh now asking black what do you want to
do
the problem is if you capture and we're
going to discuss this because if you
capture
white captures and now this diagonal
opens up and for example if bishop
captures here we just play rook to a8
with check bishop to f8 now and now we
play bishop to c4 and the black is
completely busted here there's really
not much you can do here and of course
if you capture the bishop then we just
capture it with check and we pick up the
black queen rook captures queen captures
and that's it so uh here after rook
captures and g5 instead we have rook to
a8 check by anderson not going for the
c5 okay after c5 you of course don't
have to capture i didn't mention that
you could play bishop to c7 but then
rook to a7 and still black's position is
just terrible the bishop can't move
we're threatening c captures on b6 and
it's just very very difficult to play
this with black but okay after rook
capture sun g5 anderson prefers rook to
a8 with check we have rook to g8
blocking and now queen to a4 so not as
straightforward as the line we've shown
morphe captures on a8 we have queen
captures on a8 and now queen to e8
morphe just offers a queen trade and
anderson happily trades with captures
captures and only now c5
so morphe of course doesn't capture then
uh he will lose a piece if captures
captures you're in check and you lose
the bishop here so morphy has to play
bishop back to c7 and now comes bishop
to c4 by anderson uh and this is
anderson's uh
problem in most of his games against
morphe he wants the uh he wants to
create a masterpiece that's not his own
only problem but it's one of the
problems here just going for d5 right
away is sufficient so you should really
play this the king is in check the king
moves d6 and already it's a
completely winning position for white if
morphe for example moves the bishop you
can't move the bishop here because then
we just win so you have to keep an eye
on the d8 square and now let's say
bishop c for check king to f8 and now
rook f2 and there's really not much you
can do the pawn and the bishops are
covering all of the squares around the
black king uh it's just um
impossible to hold if you try rock h5
defending just d7 attacks the knight and
there's there's no good square for the
knight
so just um
really really bad if you go here then
you allow c captures uh on b6 and if you
go knight to g7 then again c captures on
b6 and once the bishop captures uh now
of course bishop to be for check and
there's nothing for the black king to do
all of the squares are taken from him
and you have to start by giving away uh
material c5 we're happily going to
capture this and now after the bishop
captures d8 brings the queen into the
game and that's it
so uh really really uh an interesting
line but uh anderson for some reason
doesn't like d5 uh anderson plays bishop
to c4 and now okay now he is threatening
a lot of things uh but morphe uh is uh
uh morphy starts to run with his king he
just plays king to g7 and now it's not
as clean as if you've played the d5
right away so first c characters on v6
by understand again he doesn't like d5
for some reason bishop captures and now
rook to b2 now he wants his bishop pair
to stay fully operational and that this
pawn can always start marching forward
he's attacking the bishop if the bishop
moves he's bringing the rook to b7 so
his attack has merit there there is no
question about that so bishop to c7 and
the rook b7
this is the position anderson had in
mind and probably why he decided to wait
with that d5 pawn push now the bishop
can't move the knight cannot move the
rook doesn't really have all that many
squares but the king can move and uh so
morphy moves the king king to f6 hem
pins now the bishop can move
and now bishop to b4 now he waits with
the d5 move because then the king comes
to e7 and it's not it's not that clear
so first bishop to b4 now he takes away
new squares from the black king
uh and now comes rook to g6 now morphy
uh doesn't really have a good move he
has to play some like h5 h4 and try and
open up the position here and if that's
possible then he's going to get some
sort of a uh active game but if not uh
it's it's all understand this game uh
and here again not d5 bishop to f8
understand just taking away all of the
squares from morphe's king
if h4 comes then it's gonna be it's just
gonna be great so morphe starts with h5
uh but now king to f2 you don't wanna uh
wait for h4 uh with your king and g1 so
king to f2 and now h4 by morphe so you
can see it's uh although the position is
beautiful to look at it's not as
straightforward as that d5 right away
when we discussed it so here g captures
on h4 and morphe goes rook to g4 he now
wants to start claiming those pawns
we have h5 now anderson is ready to
push his pass pawn to victory rook to h4
and now h6 the bishop nicely covers this
pawn
rook captures an h2 with check king to
g1 and now rook to h3 going after the e3
pawn uh but morphy says uh sorry
anderson says nope that's not really a
threat just bishop to f1 and you can
never capture here because we just play
h7 and there's no uh stopping this pawn
from queening so after bishop to f1 rook
the g3 check king f2 and now morphy
plays rook the g4 and i think morphy is
really really trying even though his
position is worse he's really trying to
win this game if he wanted to draw he
could play rook to f3 check and it's
pretty much a guarantee to draw a king
to e2 and now bishop to g3 and now we
use the f2 square to stop the pawn if h7
rook f2 check the king has to move and
you can't move away from the bishop
because then we capture the bishop with
check and play rook to h1 and stop the
pawn so you have to play king to e1 go
under the mask of the bishop and now
rook h2 comes with a discovered check
after the king moves now we play rookie
the g6
attacked the pawn twice and now we're
going to win the pawn and also the h8
square is nicely covered
so that's that's the point
but morphe goes rook to g4 instead i
think he wants to keep winning chances
alive bishop to c for now by anderson uh
and now comes rook to h4 by morphy again
uh if morphy wanted it he could play f4
and this is i think that the most
straightforward way uh because now for
example if you play h7 then it's a
problem uh then you could play rook to
h4 uh and now what do you play here okay
uh the the pawn is now defended but
bishop g8 sorry the pawn is attacked by
bishop to g8 the defends the pawn f
captures on e3 with cher king captures
and bishop to d6 check here is one way
for for black to unwind uh and now if
rook to f7 check king to g5 we're going
to play bishop the g
bishop to g7 now threat and uh
threatened the queen our pawn so knight
will capture rook captures and now king
to f5 we're going to play rook to f7
check king to g6 and now rook to d7 we
go after the bishop bishop to f8 for
example and it's a
well it's it's a drawn end game uh the
material is completely equal the bishops
are of opposite colors so this is
definitely a possibility here so f4 uh
definitely a good idea for morphe but it
doesn't allow him to push for the win so
he plays h4 rook to h4 and now comes
bishop to g8 again uh very interesting
line is
just bishop to g7 with check and now
what do you play here uh if you capture
this with the knight then h captures and
white is winning you're either queening
the pawn or king captures and then you
lose the bishop here so what you would
have to do after this bishop the g7
check is hide the king on g6 and now
white would play bishop to e6 and we
would get this very very interesting
position where
black would very much struggle to
survive this position because the knight
cannot move uh the capture is never an
option uh due to the
line that we've shown and bishop to d7
is coming to just win the knight so uh
there's that but uh anderson again goes
for the more aesthetically pleasing line
uh he goes for bishop to g8 uh and now
morphy uh finally brings the bishop into
the game we have bishop to d6 uh
attacking the bishop here bishop
captures knight captures attacking the
anderson's rook here and now rook to d7
attacking the knight
we have knight the e8 knight to b5 is by
far the best but it's a it's a very
tricky position we have knight to e8 and
now h7 by morph by anderson we have king
the g5 and now rook to e7 going after
the knight here knight to d6 and now
rook to e6 with these few attacks on the
knight we will now claim the the c6 pawn
which would not be possible if the
knight was on b5 like we discussed uh
but okay knights to c4 we have rook
captures on c6 and not knight to d2
morphy still says all right my position
is uh
way more active you're never queening
this pawn and it's going to be very very
difficult for you to defend this
and now we've kinked e2 by anderson
maybe not the cleanest way the cleanest
way would be rook to c1 and then for
example after knight to f3 uh then only
then do we play rook back to c7 because
if we play d5 right away uh then f4 and
the morphe's position is very much
tenable yeah if he captures we're gonna
play king captures and then now well
it's even black was winning if d6 we're
just going to play rook to h2 check king
to f1 knocking to g3 and there's no
defense against uh rook to f2 checkmate
the knight covers the e1 and the g1
squares so what you would have to do
here after knight to f3
like i said is just play rook to c7 and
then start advancing the pawn and then
it's it's perfectly fine
but okay after knight to b2 anderson
played king to e2 i mean this is just
one one crazy crazy game uh and now
morphy attacks the king rook h2 check
came to d1 and now now morphy uh again
doesn't go for f4 it's like morphe
doesn't like f4 anderson didn't like c5
uh but um
for some reason it's it's definitely the
best here if if captures captures this
is now uh well
gives the morphe the most chances to
fight in this game but he played knight
to f3 and now comes rook to c7 anderson
now defends the pawn and now the bishop
can be activated uh so what do you play
here uh here we have king to g6 now
comes d5 by anderson we have f4 by
morphy finally this move is happening uh
e captures on f4 and now pawn to e3
morphy's past pawn is also uh incredible
here uh but there is one move that wins
the game for anderson uh so i i could
have uh made a pause the video moment
pretty much in every move in this game
because it's such a uh such a
well funky looking game but i decided to
do it for this one because here it's the
only move that wins the game for
anderson uh so feel free to pause the
video here and win the game uh for adolf
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the only
move that wins and it shouldn't be all
that difficult to spot because if you
allow it to check you're just lost so uh
pretty much the only way to avoid this
it's the promote this pawn to a knight
which is possible but it would yield
only a draw but rook to e7 the simplest
is the the correct here uh rook d7
congratulations to everyone who found
this and now there is no uh more chance
for for morphy here he plays that the
the best way possible he plays e to
check rook captures on e2 and now rook
to h1 check which wins him the exchange
but after king c2 knights the d for
check king to d2 knight captures and
king captures he has a rook and king
against bishop king and three pawns and
three pawns is just
a little bit too much so king g7 king to
e3 with rook to e1 check king to d4 and
now rook to f1 if he can get at least
one of these pawns off the board then he
can fight but anderson will of course
not allow this rook to e1 czech king to
f5 will rook to d1 now bishop to e6 he
even offers this pawn to morphy because
if the pawn is captured and king f6 is
enough to
win the game there's not not much you
can play here uh rook d2 would be played
let's say f5 and now black will just
waste moves king of seven king e7 and
now
any any pawn will queen and that's it so
after bishop to e6 we have rook to d4 by
morphy i'm not saying okay at least i'm
keeping an eye on this pawn push but
just king e5 by anderson rook to d1 and
now f5 uh we have rook to h1 by morphy
now comes f6 with check king captures an
h6 and now king the d6 so the only thing
that anderson could mess up here is if
he somehow
uh stalemates morphy but as you can see
he brought his king all the way to d6
and that's gonna be very hard for morphy
to achieve so rook to a1 uh we have king
to e7 rook to a7 with check bishop to d7
and he was now in this position after
bishop to b7 was played and moved 77
that paul morphy resigned the game and a
second victory for adult anderson in
this match so we will not be ending the
match with this game there will be at
least uh one more because now anderson
is starting to bounce back he already
has two victories and that's what he
meant
by this quote above the board uh he had
uh dinner with morphy he uh i think he
had the dinner with morphy after uh
every day
when the games were happening i don't
know if it was exactly every day but uh
pretty much but this is uh something
that he he mentioned
uh to to the company at the table uh
uh
the the day prior to the uh to the last
game that he's glad to have already two
sheep in safety uh meaning that he
already uh has at least two points
against morphe which you know it's not a
it's not nothing i mean it's morphy he's
playing
uh so yeah now like i said at least one
more game and here you resign because
after let's say king to g6 you have to
play something we just play f7 and
there's no the
playing this okay you have to check if
maybe you can get a draw uh
from this end game but you can see that
you know just move the king the king
guards d3 these three squares and you
know it's just a very simple win we're
just gonna push the pawn to victory so
after bishop to d7 morphe resigned and
anderson is maybe back in the match
we'll see what happens uh in the next
one his next one is really really super
exciting
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying the
match so far uh third time anderson
employs the uh the a3 opening we now
call it the grand opening he scores a
win uh first it was a loss then it was a
draw and now he improved it all the way
to a win so maybe now if he can survive
the next game with the black pieces he's
gonna uh again throw a3 at morphe
because it seems that the more this is
the opening that morphe is having the
most trouble with because it just allows
you so much you you can choose to do
anything and uh well he he just you know
got
all tangled up in the possibilities and
uh anderson came out on top uh but yeah
okay that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank richard
yarnell michael sprague david kimura
dale cook and mazin elserag for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the morphe saga
until it ends uh thank you i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day